the moment right before I jump there's a
split second there where everything goes
completely silent and that's when I push
off the edge 3 2 today I'm speaking with
a woman who kind of blows my mind my
name is Ellen Brennan and I'm a wingsuit
BASE jumper don't be modest Ellen what
else currently I'm the fastest flying
woman in the world when it comes to
wingsuit BASE jumping a wingsuit is a
special suit that inflates with air and
allows you to in essence fly or fly
Ellen does this all over the world at
crazy speeds on average I'm flying about
180 190 kilometers per hour
that's almost 120 miles per hour but to
get to that speed you need to jump off a
cliff
my vision is the first thing I notice
that everything becomes very focused on
just my feet my heart's beating super
fast it's usually beating like 160 170
beats per minute sometimes people will
talk to me and I won't even hear them as
soon as I push off I can hear the flip
of my feet off of the rock and as I
slowly start moving I can hear the wind
start to rush
like it's something that shouldn't
happen it's not natural but I'm doing it
how in the world did I get to be able to
do that one of the coolest things in the
world like have anything better to do
it's pretty mind-blowing